morning my converse high top all-stars
in honor of today's guest
dr lawrence krauss author of so many
books
uh to read their titles would take us to
the end of the podcast
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
most of the supporters of the multiverse
are fellow traveling along with string
theory and you are a
very very prominent you know kind of
outspoken
critic of of string theory and what it
might mean then you see you see i get i
get labeled well
i get laid many things i'm a critic of
hype is what i'm a criminal when it
comes to sign
so i was a critic of the hype associated
with string theory
i wrote a whole book called hiding in
the mirror which is really about
the search for extra dimensions and it
explains why string theory is very well
motivated
so this as a as a fundamental area of
physics
it's very well motivated i happen to
think probably more than loop quantum
gravity but
but but um but it's the hype
it's this interesting idea that was
claimed to be able to
tell us everything and it's told us
virtually nothing except providing an
incredible amount useful mathematical
tools
to apply to other physical systems
anyway yeah actually i i want to turn to
that because your friend
stephen hawking late great stephen
hawking he would often
you know concede bets and on the basis
of
uh of of a proof from say juan maldasena
in you know five-dimensional ads cft uh
you can recover beckon scene hawking
you can get all sorts of information but
i want to ask you like i mean i i feel
like he conceded that too easily like
how do we know that i think the ncft
even exists it's true no i
i think no i think look uh steve is a
wonderful man but he's also a very
astute
um promoter and and
i think he did some things he did
because he he realized they would get
attention
and i i i tend to think that was the
case yeah by the way i'm
really pissed that i had i had what i
thought should have been a famous bet
with
with hawking and we'll check which i won
it was shortly after
um the dark energy was discovered
that i argued and there was a great deal
of of all this
hype about all good testaments about
we'll be able to measure you know that
it's changing in blah blah and i and i
said within a decade
there will be no nothing that will be
able to tell us that
that it it it
that dark energy is changing there'll be
nothing that will able to tell you that
it is a cosmological constant and
therefore there's nothing that tells you
it isn't
and and there'll be no there'll be no
observational data and they say oh no no
no within a decade
because in his book which i have
somewhere here and i talk a beautiful
question
written in 2014 uh he makes a claim that
within five years super symmetry will be
discovered so yeah i feel of frank
that as sir roger penrose once said
though the quickest way to get rich is
to make a bet with stephen hawking
because no matter what you bet he's
going to concede because of the
attention i think
and uh and and oftentimes he would have
two different positions
but you don't become rich by being with
stephen hawk you just get some notoriety
so first of all whether i you know
putting people in camps worries me yeah
i'm not
i'm not a fan of this
claimed progress in strength here i have
great respect
for for the work that's being done in
many ways which i mean i edwin is
another friend of mine and someone i
admire tremendously for their abilities
um
but but you know but string theory isn't
quantum corner man it hasn't explained
the world
but but that has nothing to do with them
whether
a multiverse is a very sensible idea the
the the really
sensible multiverse the well-motivated
multiverse is not the multiverse of
string theory
the extra dimensional many universes the
the only one that is inescapable it
seems to me is the one from inflation
one of the knocks against string theory
is that it uh it doesn't have
um you know it doesn't make predictions
that are testable and therefore
uh cannot be cannot be falsified and
then he went into the black hole
entropy that it can be reproduced to
show the degrees of freedom that back in
a two-dimensional black hole yeah in a
two-dimensional black hole which we
don't live in by the way
exactly right so i mentioned that and
then he said okay so i said come on
cameron
and he said um so for example if you
take an electron
it has a mass and if you compute the
mass of the electron in the fundamental
units of physics which is planck mass
it's a very tiny mass in plank mass so
lawrence
what what do you what do you make of
that what would you give cameron if you
takes your
takes a cloud he's basically saying the
electron mass is prediction it could
have been
10 to the minus 32 of the of the
planck mass but it's not it's between 10
minus 31 and 10 to the minus one
um a big range but it's a prediction it
could be wrong it could be falsified i
don't think it's
well look i don't think it's worth
getting hung up because the theory is
just so premature
such an early it's not it's not a
well-defined theory yet i think and i
mean
it's got a lot of great ideas and maybe
it'll relate to the real universe at
some point
um it's as as i'd like to say and this
is a joke of frank's you know it's
promising but it's been promising and
promising for a long time
but um what really disappointed me the
most to tell you the truth is
the one thing if string theory had
predicted a cosmological constant
it would have been great but in fact not
only did it not predict a cosmological
constant but generally
it has a hard time even existing with
one and
and um without a negative one anyway and
um
yeah and so so and that's the one
i'm personally convinced that we won't
understand the energy of empty space
until we have a quantum theory of
gravity
i suspect they're intimately involved
with each other
uh and and so the one
thing that i would want a purported
theory of quantum gravity to tell me
something about
would be the cosmological constant
generally string theory would tell
would suggest that what we're seeing now
is a temporary aberration
of will ultimately be a negative uh
cosmological constant
but again then i have uh people like uh
michio kaku
coming on and saying no because i asked
him i was like where in
string theory does one find the muon g
minus two anomaly where do i find the
large hadron collider beauty results
these anomalies and so forth where do i
find hubble tension
and he says it's all there and i said
what do you mean he says you just have
to tell me
the vacuum state and i say well why is
it my job as an experimentalist tell you
what the vacuum state is of your theory
and yet on the same token the swampland
et cetera
it seems hopeless lawrence and and i'm
wondering why is it that that you get
so much attention from people like you
know kaka with the god equation
and stephen hawking even talking about m
theory as if it's proven as if all
because it sounds profound and everyone
wants the next best thing
then you know it after einstein and if
string theory
were a theory of of of uh
of space and time then obviously
in some level and if there and a
complete theory that
from which all the forces of nature were
derivable then obviously
it's in there because ever you know if
it really were a theory of
all the forces of nature then all the
things we measure must be a part of that
so so it's a tautology almost so of
course in principle it's there
but we don't but first of all a we don't
know how to do it but
more importantly than that we don't know
if it is we don't know if it
if this incredibly fascinating area of
mathematical physics
is a fundamental description of our
universe and i don't really care about
at this point whether it makes
predictions that you could test because
i i think that's we're way away from
that
the question we really have to address
is that there's no evidence yet
string theory describes
uh uh our universe if you enjoyed this
video i know you'll want to check out my
interview with frank wilczak winner of
the 2004 nobel prize
in this conversation frank and i discuss
this fascinating new book
called fundamentals which outlines 10
key principles to understand our
universe
and don't forget to subscribe